star de cinéma géant de la politique ou
sportif légendaire yousuf karsh un
photographié les plus grands avec une
sensibilité et une maîtrise incomparable
ce extraordinaire des conversions
aujourd'hui
techniquement
les poils qui lève ses bras
l'exposition l'univers de yousuf karsh
l'essence du sujet permet de découvrir
les sens photographique et sa veuve
venait d'offrir au musée des beaux-arts
de montréal un regard privilégié sur les
grandes figures du siècle dernier cette
capacité de capter l'essence de sujet
justement cette phrase qui fait partie
de titre de l'exposition qu'on voulait
présenter ce son travail parce que c'est
une exposition qui it à la fin très très
humaine yousuf karsh à émigrer seul au
canada en 1908 pour fuir le génocide
arménien si cette photo de winston
churchill qui lui ouvre les portes d'une
carrière internationale bon moi je veux
pas la photo et les cigares je vais la
voir qui me lagarde puis m16 bien tout
le temps fatigué s'est approché et
enlever les cigares cas quand les
photographes il faut qu'on soit capable
de la personne qui est en train de lui
faire comprendre qu'on travaille on
travaille pour cette personne là on veut
montrer qu'ils aient les deux grands
québécois aussi opposé pour lui
notamment jean-paul-riopelle ou irratia
zilina on voit des moments un très
intime qui sont captés dans chacune de
ses images et donc il ya une chaleur
dans cette exposition
est une sorte
intimity mais il a aussi photographié
des ouvriers et des gens ordinaires et
l'allemagne à mettre les sujets à l'est
et trouver un moment tellement
expressive l'été une grande humaniste
elle a cherché d'exprimer
les relations entre les zones diverses
les images sont accompagnées de textes
explicatifs qui raconte dans les mots du
photographe décédé en 2002 six
rencontres avec ces sujets les
photographies de yousuf karsh nous
permettent de regarder l'histoire droit
dans les yeux ici n'est bien lexandre
chartier radio canada montréal